who I admire it's a common question I
get a lot of podcasts and interviews and
the reality is
this
this is what I most admire the
individuals in the world who are able to
take a step back and deploy humility
and hard work to reset when they've over
extended themselves financially I really
worry about where a lot of people took
advantage of all the dollars that pumped
in
the covid and
imprinted and then people got checks and
they bought Dom p and Supremes and
instead of putting it in a bank or
for work now people are overextended
jobs are getting
the lot going on in the system and for
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of millions this move right here above
is the big one Maddie I admire you and
you and your wife so much it's it's
massive and
I think about the step backwards from
two steps forward